it's time for the week two superlatives
what do you got well i'm gonna go you
ever seen the movie king of new york
christopher walken right you ever seen
that one that's a good one you need to
watch that but mcdermott okay buffalo
bills are the king of new york all right
that's what i think i gotta talk about
them a little bit you know josh allen's
my boys my boy blue you can have a catch
with him again and have other people
that actually do the catching no no i'd
like to go so i can just talk and not
worry about getting hit in the face by
one of his lasers but either way the
buffalo bills two-and-oh let's give them
a little credit they had to play two
road games to start their season jets
giants first time in metlife stadium
didn't play well played phenomenal in
the second half to come back give
themselves a chance to win yesterday
against the giants giants get off to a
great start first drive of the game
saquon barkley but really from that
point on uh josh allen made a number of
big time plays on third down and things
to get them to the 21-7 lead he is a
threat because of his movement and
because of his big arm he puts
tremendous stress on the defense and
then you know mcdermott isn't he's one
of the best defensive coaches in
football just very impressed with what
i've seen from the buffalo bills
yesterday was impressive i think the way
they rebounded up their sloppy first
half and week one was almost the most
impressive thing they've done this year
or is the most impressive thing i talked
to josh allen after the game yesterday
and i said how tempting will it be to
peek past the bengals and look at the
patriots coming up in week four oh we
take them one game time i said i i look
how tempting will it be to peek past the
bengals and consider what's coming and
he said we're going to do everything we
can to focus on the next game and you
know if they do that they could be three
and oh he's drinking the kool-aid
three-and-oh he knows what he's got to
do hey
and they're the one team in the afc east
that looks like they will at least have
a chance
to make it interesting yes be a pain in
the butt at least nonetheless but that
leads to my yeah
2007 all over again award right
remember how 12 years ago when they just
came out and destroyed everyone they
weren't close games like the 72 dolphins
had some close games right the patriots
didn't have many close games especially
early there were some close games late
as they were trying to seal the deal
like against baltimore and the giants
but early on they were just dismantling
everyone and this is a patriots team
that's not supposed to be this good in
september what's been the narrative for
the last five or six years in new
england yeah you want to catch them
catch them early september you want to
get them on monday night football like
they were in kansas city five years ago
that that notorious on to cincinnati
moment which in many ways
sparked this second act of patriots
greatness they hadn't won a super bowl
in 10 years when the on to cincinnati
quote was uttered it's almost like that
moment was the lawnmower accord on what
we've seen this run of greatness where
they've been to every super bowl but won
since the the instant where bill
belichick said on to cincinnati 33-3
over the steelers right 43 to nothing
over the dolphins that's 76 to 3
in eight quarters of football you throw
the super bowl on top of it it's 89 to
6. it's phenomenal suffocation yes not
even close scary the defense is so good
brady's amazing i mean if you want me to
self-scout okay my quarterback rankings
i messed up with brady i'll tell you
that right now i mean i had him nine i
was wrong i'm about to put him now he's
definitely he'd been five or six
somewhere in that area i mean he's
definitely better than matt ryan cam
newton and ben roethlisberger certainly
so i'm i'm here as i always am being
transparent to tell you i was wrong on
that one for sure just amazing what
brady's doing but damn did they teach
some lessons there yesterday i mean i
felt like it was like they were still
throwing the ball in the fourth quarter
and i feel like bill was like oh yeah
you guys want to go down to miami and
like ditch me and the whole staff wants
to go down there and live the life let
me teach you guys the lessons this ain't
as easy as it looks but but he always
does that i remember that was one of the
narratives in 2007 they were destroying
people why are you doing it they were
just playing the game yeah playing the
game yeah right they play the game right
this is professional football this isn't
pee-wee where you got to feel bad
because your team you know you guys are
shaving and the other kids are running
around and they're diapers i mean this
is yeah it's not his job
exactly right and uh he did what he had
to do so that's mine okay and that's a
good one i feel like it's going to be a
weekly thing for the new england
patriots yeah it's uh it's scary it's
looking like they could uh be
i mean they might not lose a game i
don't even know they're amazing either
way here's my next one money money money
money you know who's gonna get money
money money
yeah baby it's just cha-ching every week
boom boom i gotta give dak
prescott the cowboys offense in general
i mean phenomenal through the first two
weeks and i know it was the giants and
the redskins and we're not expecting
them to make super bowl runs but it
doesn't matter it's the manner in which
they're doing it and it's they're doing
it a lot of different ways week one they
relied on the pass game made some big
plays week two same thing pass game but
oh zeke looked a week better he looked
great yesterday i mean they're just
they're scary right now calvin moore i
just can't say enough about what he's
doing as an offensive coordinator we my
biggest question mark about the football
team jason garrett congratulations that
was a gutsy move to name kellen moore
the offensive coordinator and it's paid
off but dak prescott this offense but
especially dak prescott has been on the
money precision passing big time throws
oh and when you need him to run he can
do that too i i just i i'm so impressed
with what i've seen on the cowboys on
the offensive side of the ball 26 for 30
269 yards three touchdowns one pick for
prescott and another 69 yards running
the ball on five attempts that's 13.8
yards per attempt and that is a total of
300 338 yards from scrimmage for dak
prescott but dual threat quarterback who
you know it's not like it's a key part
of the game plan yeah but it's there
when you need it to be right and it
bails you out of some bad situations
that's right it does keep you honest you
can't you can't go man all the way down
the field right abandoned in the middle
over there to go zeke elliott on the
back side because he might keep it and
go and get you and that was my upset
special week i was feeling good about
that one uh thank you
but that didn't last forever where you
gonna go all right uh how about the this
ain't the minneapolis miracle award okay
stefan diggs who had that moment for the
ages when he scored the touchdown at the
end of the game against the saints
stood in the end zone threw his helmet
off you you only get away with that one
once stefan because now if you take your
helmet off after a touchdown which he
did yesterday when he scored a key
touchdown that would have made it 21 to
14 at the half after the vikings were
down 21 nothing early it would have been
just a huge momentum booster to be 2114
instead of 2110.
diggs takes the helmet off and we're in
the viewing room we're saying oh they oh
yeah right away yeah yeah right away and
i thought they weren't going to call it
yeah and then it was clear that they had
called it and the difference this year
and here's why you want to be very
careful how you celebrate whether it's
taking your helmet off whether it's
having a prolonged celebration whether
it's hiding a cell phone under the
padding the goal post if you do that
the 15-yard penalty can be applied to
the try not the kickoff it used to just
be the kickoff now the defense can
choose where it's going to be applied
and the packers wisely said hey 15 yards
on the try so it's either a 17-yard
two-pointer or a 48-yard field goal for
the one-pointer and dan bailey missed it
yeah so when he did score that touchdown
i'm getting i'm getting my uh my uh that
was early in the third quarter i got my
circle i'm so flustered by that whole
game it was 21-16 at the time it would
have been 21-17 but that point
we know you're pointing this
touchdown that was taken away in 21-14
sorry about that and the 21-16 instead
of 21-17 it's just it felt like the
vikings were just bogged down by
self-inflicted wounds yep and you were
picked a couple of cousins and i took
aaron rodgers and i won i i like to sing
to mike in my italian voice every now
and then and that's what i was doing her
cousins was 13 for 31 their passing game
and it's not just kirk cousins it's
there's an issue there schematically i
i'm i'm and i know he's not perfect but
there's issues there it's just not
creative there's no intermediate past
there's nothing it's right it's
basically it's either home
or it's throw it out on the field
exactly right there's there's no meat
and potatoes to the passing offense
right now they got to get that figured
out um
i don't i want to go i don't even know
how to like say this but i you just want
to be like i want to be like i want to
just call this like running back and
then i want to do like my good fellas
ray leota
[Laughter]
running back you think you should play
run receiver
what is that lamar jackson i know that i
have no i can't do the right leo to
laugh on goodfellas i couldn't do it i
don't know but i just want to say like i
mean are you kidding me with what lamar
jackson's doing right now oh it's
incredible it's incredible i mean i
don't have a that was my phrase i don't
know what the hell that was supposed to
be with my super what is your
superlative it was just like are you
kidding me like running back receiver
all these people who tried to play offs
yeah right that's what i was trying to
do kind of and just like give a
sarcastic laugh like that's ridiculous
lamar jackson proving people wrong for
the second week in a row and it's not i
mean again his running was phenomenal
yesterday he he showed kyler murray like
oh yeah you think you're faster well i'm
a little faster 16 for 120 running the
football
but forget that it's the throws and the
variety of throws we're seeing from
lamar jackson that i think are
phenomenal right now 24 for 37 272 two
touchdowns and hey yeah you're gonna
look at some of these highlights and go
well yeah they're wide open okay they
are wide open but you know why some of
them are wide open because lamar jackson
and his skill set puts defenses and
binds to have to do things they just
don't want to do and then he takes
advantage of it but he's showing the
ability to throw a touch feel in the
pocket drop his arm and throw some
sidearm balls we've seen a number of
times the last few weeks so i just am
proud of him
and the baltimore ravens offense greg
roman everything they've done they've
really like like mike what we talk about
so much
they have something great they do and
they make you play to it our run game's
great and they pubbed it up oh you're
gonna see things and defenses are coming
in right now going oh we got to stop
this run and lamar is just laughing he's
going okay well i can throw it now and
you better watch out and i got some
weapons there's a swagger too to lamar
there is i talked earlier about how
mason rudolph looks like
what am i doing here right like what
deer in the headlights i stepped through
a portal and here i am what in the world
is this a dream lamar jackson there was
a run yesterday where he broke to the
left and he did a little bit of a high
step yeah yeah yeah hesitation like this
is a guy who is in complete and con and
total control
of of his uh surroundings his game and
everything
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports